hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the  trailer for Jupiter ascending  I love the Wachowski things so it would  what do you call them brother and sister  now brothers I don't know  I love the Wachowski siblings yes  doesn't sound as cool so glad to go back  to sci-fi you're the perfect home soon  machine neo fearless relentless  dangerous you'll be searching for one  thing your whole life and she's down  there make sure this is the right one  it's her good but of his ears  it can be difficult for people from  underdeveloped worlds to hear that their  planet is not the only inhabited planet  King was the best song zero ever win  since the battle it's just what you say  she is a very small part of a very large  industry almost awesome ass  I feel I have someone for disadvantage  that because he kidnapped me  of music  yes Hollywood tensity great teaser man  I just really hope it's a science  fiction movie I'll understand the Matrix  Reloaded and [ __ ] was hard to keep up  with